so assist again in the absence of the
vice-chairman I can just start as usual
with our emergency evacuation
announcement in the event of a fire or
other emergency please exit the building
in an orderly manner to the assembly
point which is located in the market car
park there are two fire exits located in
the room clearly indicated by the green
fire exit signs please do not delay the
evacuation by collecting any belongings
the premises must not be reentered until
on fire brigade have given the all-clear
you please notice is against the law to
smoke on these premises please also
remember that this meeting will be audio
recorded please stand for the Chairman
the Chairman's chat good evening members
had praise on my chapling thank you very
much indeed I've just a couple of words
as I anyone and it be any last meeting
Carol actually announced that I done had
a job change and just to explain I am to
be the Archdeacon of south end as of the
19th of March thank you very much to me
thank you I appreciate that such just
this is the flow is just disappears now
what's outfit I knew I was good to say
moments ago and just did to say a lot of
people say what does a large d can do
but if anyone can tell me it was really
really cultural I've been doing the job
the last six months as Acting Archdeacon
and first of all my title changes I lose
my title of the Reverend Canon and i
become the venerable just in case you
wonder yeah it's no bearing that's okay
inside I'm still Mike just remember that
okay and the other thing I'd say is that
actually the role of the Archdeacon is
very much in support of the churches in
the archdeaconry of south end covers
Rochford south end basildon Hadley and
thorac so it's a very large area 88
churches
and their population of folk but is to
support the ministry of those churches
that are also to deliver the strategic
plans of the diocese as well so it's a
more strategic role as senior staff role
working very much alongside the bishops
and with other colleagues as well that
that's basically I just want to explain
that and for those if you'd like to come
along I'm going to be collated and
installed I'm not sure about the stapled
bit but where that comes into it a no it
didn't really on the 19th of marching
chance of cathedral if anyone wants to
trot along at three-thirty you're really
very welcome but I understand everyone's
got busy lives I think Karen's coming
from sleep yeah so if you'd like to come
along if you're very welcome to do so I
was reflecting on this sort of being
called into doing things that sometimes
we're not quite sure what we meant to be
doing and thinking about as a council
I'm sure you know exactly what you're
doing and you have a particular role in
the community which I know is valued
very much by the community and as I
think I said at the last meeting this is
actually a fantastic community and I'm
only going to be moving across the road
to thundersley so not far away so I
should be keeping an eye on you all but
we've all got a role to play and I
thinking about this in terms of what we
actually do and Jesus actually had some
words to say about those choosing those
to do a particular role and he chose a
hotchpotch of people actually he chose a
few fishermen he chose a tax collector
who was hated by everybody in the
community and he also chose a guy who
was in our terms today was a terrorist
actually and he also chose somebody who
betrayed him and then when I can hanged
himself actually a real hot bunch of
people but what's interesting is that
what whatever background we've got
actually we can all be cool to do
something really important for Jesus
disciples he called them to actually
share something of the love of God and a
real message of hope and peace in the
world of need and that message remains
exactly the same today let's pray
first of all a prayer of thanksgiving
for all of our council employees
Heavenly Father we thank you for all
council employees we thank you for their
skills and experience for all their
dealings with elected councillors and
with a public we pray that helpfulness
courtesy and tact may characterize all
their work and that the quality of
administration may be reflected in the
quality of community life as we thank
you for their concern and commitment in
all that they do for us as we pray for
this meeting Almighty God we pray for
those who hold office in the life of
this district and all that they do in
service to the community we pray for
this meeting that it's careful
preparation may bring about fruitful and
considered discussion and decision
making we pray that all who are here
today fulfilling their duties with
singleness of purpose may wisely and
effectively exercise the authority
committed to them and promote the common
good we are these prayers in Jesus name
Amen thank you very much for listening
you would be pleased to hear I've only
got two more meetings to go so you won't
have to hear all my face a lot okay lets
you see okay your bets are now price
makes it members
apologies list okay members number one
app on your epson so we have count for
mrs. butcher count through a Robin Dre
count to jay newport council are awesome
are there any other apologies please
thank you madam chairman council Mini
Cooper thank you very much
minutes of the lot of a meeting held in
the 30s end of 2016 he'll agree can I
sign them as a correct record members to
receive declaration of interest
announcements a number for announcements
from the chair chairman or leader or
head of Paige services the only
announcement I'd like to make is
counselor butcher some of you may know
I've hadn't done any operation just to
let you know she's doing very very well
probably too much cause it's hurtin and
more than it usually does but she'll be
up and around in the next one of a few
weeks any other announcements this stage
in the meeting will include the
presentation of the Gideon Bible to the
chairman Roger oxen will present the
Gideon Bible please southie aesthetics
most in this presentation responsible
shadow on over it Lynette I'm only
deputizing tonight one of our neighbors
Gary Gareth Evans who is seriously ill
but is recover it is recovering was
hoping absolutely yesterday stood to
make this presentation but just what a
very was looking forward to carrying a
selfie well then I have half a million
people are begins obviously having 7e
and most of you are Guineans fact one of
a hundred years been operating and
starting with the beginni enviable in my
hotels in a small way in America weather
over the period of time 100 years now
Branson worldwide organization operating
200 countries and the travel of annually
now bother giving in Bibles or New
Testaments we actually give up 85
million
now two hotels but a hospital in silence
at alderley prisoners emergency services
of military colleges particularly school
isn't passing a couple of minutes I'd
like to see pages school is in the area
east essex we have about 24 25 schools
and delighted but most of me still
actually will still actually welcomed us
so far this school year since sep tember
and bidding at about 3,000 customers and
people easily in yes then the conclusion
of an assembly and one of disinformation
with one of the idea to get pimples
aware what we can value my gaps and we
met the new testament and then it's
probably some of you probably have had
one of these when you're in school they
talk about their cost begins about a
pound each will groups later but if you
are often a penalty no test earlier you
will accept the penalty eligibly guess
yes sending the majority of payments
better go straight back and to get an
idea that mentally the idea that wagon
will point out the value is not the same
as cops and the reason why we use that
value the book is that was it for the
message that we give that it is that we
find interval and in particular this is
a particular thing to do and four years
of gathering it was the Queen's Jubilee
because we can come back
coronation itself I would say you remain
women then giving many recall because
they nearly fatal places on the line if
not older you may know that it means a
legacy was presented with a viable in
these words of this exam we've
essentially with this book the most
valued would be that miss work
performance when you lower the things
they're found Jones with all the sector
things worth millions and that yes book
ends because of the message that they
will contain well that was over 60 years
ago millions and certainly agree with
that statement has what only that it was
treated with only years it's still true
today despite and changes will take
place in society probably the best way I
think I've been presented to you madam
chair if I same words and it's a do you
Liam subscribe to insane on behalf of
the local billions in southeast ethics
which presented with this group which is
still moving isn't like study looking at
this
[Applause]
number five members public questions and
member of questions on notice there are
none I'm six business for the last
council meeting there are none number
seven to note the minutes of the
executive and committee meeting till
between the period 26 and November 16 to
soda februari 17 as listed are these
notice members took number 8 to consider
any reports from the executive and
committees to counsel the treasury
management strategic statement I
understand councillor Burton who learn
to present the report please Thank You
chairman as the report state the
council's treasury management strategy
statement was brought before the review
committee on the 72 fed the section 151
officer given a detailed explanation of
what was contained within the statement
was at the same time addressing
questions put forward by members as a
result the review committee therefore
recommended that the council approves
the report before us tonight with
recommendations contained therein if any
members have got any further questions
understand they can address those
directly to section 151 officer who's
here tonight thank you any questions
members mode members will take will take
the recommendation as a whole please
that agreed
number nine report on urgent divisions
is this noted members number ten report
of the lead on the work of the Executive
Council cut more please thank you very
much chairman right this is the fourth
ordinary council meeting for the 1617
municipal year since annual council and
I would like to welcome all members
since the meeting on the 13th December
masses that my colleagues and I on the
executive in dealing with include a
response to the London mayor's
consultation on a draw a vision for the
city a response to buzzard and borough
councillors consultation on new and
alternative sites a response to South
Main borough council's 2016 revised
proposed submission draft of the south
in central area action plan a response
to Essex County Council and south in
Borough Council's main modifications
consultation for draft waste local plane
and a caravan site fee and policy
licensing fees as always I'd be happy to
take any questions from members in
respect to the work of the executive and
I'm sure my executive colleagues will be
happy to compute contribute where
appropriate Thank You chairman thank you
counter cut more yes council back um
that's the question regarding the public
health quarter physically 6,000 pounds
what is the current intentional and have
that will be the hell that will be spent
German are not even aware of a public
health current coming forward is it
passes the executives work i'm not sure
that it is well done if they're 151
officer can help me out here please
answer the question and I'll deviances
so rewrite come back to you in a minute
counsel back with the answer any other
questions at all members counter black
eye room I understand it's the next item
that's no problem at all
members are number 11 motions are notice
there are none number 12 fit in the
council tax 2017-18 to consider report
of the section 151 officer Rob Manning
will present the report please Thank You
chair and okay good evening everyone and
I emailed you last night stating about
we were potentially and received a
financial settlement and police say we
were some ways we've received the
financial settlement and there was
actually no chance that the numbers were
exactly the same as what we expected so
in one way that's quite good but clearly
that means that government hasn't
listened to to local authorities when
they say the pressure is really mounting
and they haven't taken that on board so
that's a slight disappoint from our
point of view that we didn't have a you
know any sort of whim for anything at
the last minute so so the figures you
see in the report are as is they are the
final figures and that's what I'll be
precise your you know your review and
resolution this evening so viously this
report is very slightly different to the
MTF s which I presented last week in
effect what this does is you've set the
you've set the budget for rockford and
the and the council tax amount for
rockford district council and what this
does he sums everything up in terms of
what also has to be paid for Essex
County Council police and fire obviously
what I'm not asking you to do is approve
their individual increases or changes
that's not what we're saying that's all
done by their own councils this is just
about whether it comes for us and
actually basically we have to do it so
like I say the report is there it's
fairly self-explanatory a lot of the
appendices we've got how it's all broken
down into an average bandy and then
across each of the bands for each of the
parishes and districts it's a parison
sorry and and I'll happily take any
questions and still think about capsule
black counter counter cut more please
Jenna this is my report on from the
leader on setting the council tax
chairman and through you councillors
members of the public and press this is
my 13th budget lucky for some as leader
of the Conservative administration the
budget pressures under its local
government operates of intensified and
this Authority continues to look closely
at opportunities for savings and most
importantly at how we can increase
revenue this is not only in response to
cutscene levels of grants and spending
power but also to significant cost
increases from the demographic pressures
revenue support grant or HD funding will
be a hundred percent withdrawn from
2018-19 this follows historic cuts of
fifty-four percent in 1617 from one
point to 4 1,000,000 being received in
2015-16 worse still there will be a
point 63 million payment requirement by
2019 20 so its in- this means that
Rochford district council must take
control of its financial position and
become self-sustaining by 2021 along
with the impact of demographic changes
and inflation pressures there will be a
budget gap of around 2.1 million by 2021
this must be met through savings plans
revenue growth and potential funding
options looking to the future we have a
business plan that sets the high level
priorities that the council will work
towards in the next three years its
themes give a focus on capital
investment and provide a clear direction
to inform the better use of council
resources to deliver priorities
priorities are to use early intervention
to manage demand for our services to
maximise their assets and to enable
communities despite the challenges faced
we have continued to deliver excellent
services to our residents our
achievements over the past year include
successfully setting up a new local
authority trading company to help
generate income and make us less reliant
on government fund
green gateway trading limited was set up
in December 2016 and its subsidiary
green gateway trading GM limited has
just been awarded as first contract
exactly three contracts now I think by
an external organization it will be
carrying out grounds maintenance works
for barling Magna Parish Council
Watchers 8 Thark trail delivered in
partnership with local artists
exhibiting a diverse and exciting
selection of art craft and design in the
town shops cafes and businesses Raley
windmill has once a game in accredited
as a quality assured visitor attraction
by visit England for the eighth year in
a row the iconic building has security
this produces I can't say prestigious
visit England seal of approval our 13th
annual Wildwood study which took place
on the fourth autumnal hockey woods and
attracted over four thousand visitors
who had the chance to try their hand at
activities including axe throwing books
crafts and tent building holding up
hosting a parish and town council summit
in January to enable close to working
and focus on issues which affect all the
authorities continuing to provide local
businesses with advice and support
including hosting various business and
school some events awarding grants
totaling 35,000 to a range of community
initiatives around the district
receiving a public health grant of
26,500 the majority of which was
allocated for health and well-being
supporting the community in the answers
your question for the six year holding
the young intrapreneurs again in
partnership with enterprise in education
when local schools took part in special
challenges to prove that had the skills
to succeed in the world of work being
one of just 28 national partnerships
chose to become one of the government's
network for homeless prevention
trailblazers this has helped secure
funding which will benefit some of the
district's most vulnerable people being
third in the country ads of more than
350 authorities for recycling with a
recycling rate of 66 26 a 20 million
funding boost from the southeast local
enterprise partnership for a new
business park which will be located in
the Rockford
district as a responsible counsel we
will continue to look at the areas where
costs can be reduced or income generated
however in 1718 there is a need to
increase council text by one point nine
five percent to help fund the huge
financial strain that the district is
currently facing this equates to an
increase of 8p per household per week
Annette's for a bendy property the
proposal ESET is syd ruptured district
councils council tax for a bet I think
it's bandaged should be property 217
pounds seventeen pence per year the
breakdown of annual council tax for
bandy property would be Essex County
Council 1163 bound 70 police and crime
Commissioner for Essex 157,000 five
minutes Essex fire and rescue or
authority 69 pounds of three points
average town and parish council come to
44 pounds and 39 pins and our own
counsel of C 217 17 the total average
council tax for AB and E property for
2017 would be 165 1.3 for an increase of
47 pounds and 34 pins approximately two
point nine five percent in conclusion
although these are still difficult
Financial Times Roger District Council
remains committed to providing excellent
services to our residents and partners
with this in mind we'll be doing all we
can to deliver energies and the high
quality services Chairman I commend
watch for district council tax for
members approval thank you madam
chairman Thank You counsel come on
council john mason food thank you seven
i would just like to thank mr. Manning
once again and everyone else is
supported they nearly there in this
plane you've only got to survive a few
more minutes and then you can sleep
seriously thank you very much further
than your silence such a coherent report
just a few quotes pressure is really
mounting said mr. Manning believe it's a
huge financial strain the withdrawal of
the rs3 is getting
very close uncomfortably close some
people say and we are going to have to
start looking critically at the delivery
dates for the investment projects that
we are currently running through the
investment board we are going to have to
be very critical about sibuk sleepings
may places in a difficult position we're
just going to have to work smarter and
probably harder there was one thing the
leader thickness from his speech and
that is about in terms of these projects
not only are we seeking to be
self-sufficient financially but also he
missed out talking about and where it's
appropriate to also provide social
benefit and I don't want to see us lose
sight of the opportunity for social
benefit out of the investments that
we're making it's not just about closing
that ridiculous gap the government's
placed ourselves in maybe we can do it
at the same time the increases in
council tax and payments to other
authorities are often quoted quoted in
pennies per week however if you will
start looking at the overall now and the
leader did set this out we're now
talking about for overall we're going
we're getting near to a pound a week so
let's not talk about any let's put it
into a proper perspective as we're
proving tonight on behalf of ourselves
and the other authorities all of the
other presets whilst the percentages
increases are currently being
constrained I can see a time soon giving
these these terms pressure is really
melting through special straight I can
see a time soon when a different
Chancellor may well decide that council
tax can be increased a
of the current cats in fact I see has
certainly inevitability for that let's
not run away with great Glee because if
you're talking about what two-point-nine
percent overall does to a family's
budget think what would happen if it was
four or five times that size we are in
difficult circumstances we have to think
carefully about the future and also the
future of council tax i'd also put out a
such certain warning to our third tier
councils with parishes and our town
council so far you've not been capped
maybe you won't maybe you'll be able to
carry on raising the presets far harder
than the cap district and other councils
just need to make that warning and also
our warning to us is don't rely upon the
third tier councils to bail us out it
may not be possible yes we do have in a
completely enviable services and I'd
like to draw attention to one in
particular I'd also draw attention to
recycling and yes we are number three in
the country and we've been amongst that
top three one way or another since 2008
but one of the things that has changed
members is that the cost of this
recycling have changed dramatically we
are now getting close to 1.4 million net
total costs in fact this year the total
cost went up by nearly 200,000 so at
some point we've got today four pretty
close look at our recycling costs I'm
sure if you ask our residents of what
they think are our top services I'm sure
those daily cycling but I wonder ham you
can realize how much of our council tax
actually goes into the cycling nearly
1.4 million net total cost is a huge
amount of money I'm not against
recycling I'm just saying it has to be
put into
back to a maybe insightful review Thank
You German i will as we did as I said
last advanced extraordinary council
meeting I will be supporting the
increase in council tax for this
district principally because I see that
there's going to be a huge need for
increased costs increase expenditure on
the homeless reduction bill if we didn't
raise this money then our reserves would
be plundered that's not necessarily a
bad thing I remember mr. Bickle's saying
it was a really good thing that counters
had the reserves you expected them to
use them but in this case I think
putting the council tax one point nine
percent leaves us a bit of room for the
homeless reduction bill costs thank you
truly Thank You counsel John Mason
council black would you like the 151
officer Bob Manning to answer your
question now Thank You Jay and yeah I
can see in the budget in life I've got
the detail of the spend on me I'll take
it way to the ID responsibility thank
you to a book either this relates to the
livewell agenda and I think there's a
joint funded poor service between what
should and castle point that will come
back with with more detail in it in due
course you're welcome cancel Emily
Thank You chairman if I could just add
to that there is a plan of small and
some not quite for small projects
attached to some of that spend that it's
also part of that was the missing
members from the parish summit we had
recently would be announcement for 500
pound to each parish to come up with
their own wealth health and well-being
project within their area and there's a
possibility of a larger sum up from from
the overall allowance if something
worthwhile comes forward Thank You
counsel Emily castle hook my please
thank you madam chairman I just like to
say a couple of things just to give a an
overview of what we're looking at today
and with regard to our residents they
will hold us accountable for raising
their costs but they will probably
accept this if we can provide
sufficiently good reasoning for doing so
our residents will expect something in
return for increases in their costs and
therefore we need to be able to justify
that unfortunately we are looking to not
only increase costs on our residents but
possibly even cut near services this is
a byproduct of what is happening from
central government in taking away
financing to our local authorities to
provide good services through our
residents and I think it is it it's
incumbent upon us to get that message
across otherwise if we do not then our
residents will have a dim view on us as
an authority Thank you Thank You
counselor counselor cut multi
thank you Jim and I welcome the comments
from the other counselors there just to
say to him and I think Rochford district
is into the future in a reasonably good
position but there are still unknowns as
you know the plan for the government is
that the National the non-domestic rate
will actually come to councils but we
don't yet know what that comes with
there will be duties that will come with
that but that's yet to be found now
whether that will work in our favor or
not we don't know but at least we know
that we have a thriving airport on a
midst we have a good shopping centres
raleys doing well at the moment yes of
course they're all struggling in their
own way but you know in in in in as much
as they're delivering a service they're
actually doing very well and they've got
a good reputation and going forward
chairman we've got the airport and we've
got the business park that is really
coming forward now and hopefully that
will give us if we are to take on
business rates some good income in the
future so I think you know there's very
few areas that have got that sort of
drive behind them and I think we're well
placed I think we have a local plan that
is going through a lot of places don't
so they don't exactly know where housing
and commercial services will come from
and I think Rochford is in much demand
as far as businesses coming in and
looking at this and thinking this is not
only good place to do business it's a
good place to live as well so I think
going for the future on quite optimistic
but of course we have to have those
safeguards coming forward thank you Jim
thank you counter cut more members
dental recommendations we're going to
take them one to ten but to need to be
done by recorded vote Sundra has other
cases thank you
counselor black or chain yes please
counselor Burton counselor Carter
counselor mrs. gustav counselor cut more
cancer st counselor mrs. Gooding
counselor Griffin or counselor Hazelwood
cancel a hook way counselor Diane hoy
councillor michael hoy canceling seduce
cancer you are new cancer Lucas kill
counselor mrs. Lumley cancel the
Christine Mason can serve Elliot Mayson
cancer John Mason councillor Marek
counselor lil counselor mountain
counselor mrs. Rowe cancel mrs. Shaw
countless less or counselor sparing
Chancellor Stanley cancer step to cancel
award or counselor web Council is
Western for counselor Williams counselor
Wilson
members are carried unanimously thank
you very much
you